كلمه واحده هي السر هي السعاده هي
الاستقرار هي الحب هذا ليس كلاما من الشعر
بل من العلم دراسه شملت 40 الف حالا زواج
على مدار 50 عاما توصلت الى سر مشترك
لنجاح العلاقات الزوجيه كلمه شكرا فبحسب
الدراسه التي نشرها موقع شبكه سيم بي سي
فان العلماء وجدوا عاملا مشتركا واحدا بين
جميع الازواج يتلخص في انهم يريدون ان
يكونوا في موضع تقدير وان يتم الاعتراف في
جهودهم وبحسب الدراسه هذه الحاجه للحصول
على التقدير يجب ان يلبي بها الطالب في
الاخر ويوصل باحثون بان يقدم الازواج
لبعضهم عبارات الشكر والتقدير اذا باختصار
كلمه السر في نجاح العلاقات الزوجيه مع
زينب
تخيلوا معي ان سر نجاح العلاقه الزوجيه
يكمن في كلمه واحده هكذا يبدو الامر سهلا
انها كلمه نرددها يوميا ولعده مرات مع
زملائنا في العمل او الاشخاص المستطرقين
في حياتنا اليوميه لكن هذه الكلمه تحمل من
التقدير الكثير ما يجعل علاقتنا بالشريك
مزدهره
هذا الحديث لم ياتي من فراغ انها دراسه
علميه اجرها معهد جوت مان لعلم النفس شملت
40 الف حالتي زواج على مدار 50 عاما اكدت
نتائجها ان العلاقه الزوجيه الفريده بنيت
اساسا على كلمتي شكرا
سالنا بعض الازواج ان كانوا يتبادلون
كلمات الشكر والامتنان في علاقاتهم وهل
اسهمت هذه العبارات بانجاح علاقاتهم
العلاقه الزوجيه اللي اللي بين الزوجين
نسبه الكلمات الشكر بين الزوجين
تعزز العلاقه الابديه همم بين الزوجين
بين الزوجين بشكل صادق بيناتهم وتزيد الى
زياده الموده والمحبه بين الطرفين كلمات
الشكر وكلمات العرفان وكلمات الامتنان
مهمه بكل العلاقات يعني لكن العلاقه
الزوجيه احيانا
بعض الازواج فاقدين هذه الكلمات
لن اقول لكم تعالوا لنتغاضى عن سلبيات
بعضنا البعض لكن لا باس لو ركزنا
بالايجابيات قليلا ومن اللطيف جدا ان
نعترف بجهد الاخر والمثير بالاهتمام ان
الدراسه ذاتها اكدت ان لكلمات الشكر دورا
مهما بالحد من ارتفاع نسبه الطلاق زينب
المشتى صباح العربيه بغداد
هو عنده العادات والحاجات اللي تربي عليها
وهي عندها نفس الكلام لو هو تقبل الاختلاف
وهي تقابلت الاختلاف هيعرفوا يعدوا اللي
بينهم لان تقبل الاختلاف ده في حد ده
بدايه النجاح
[موسيقى]
تقدر تخلي العلاقه الزوجيه كويسه والراق
الزوجيه مش كويسه لو انت واخذ واحده بنت
اصول في وقت الشده تشيلك
هتنجح يعني كل واحد يبقى واثق في الثاني
بس انا شايفه ان دي اكثر حاجه يعني
هو في الشغل في
الماليه في شؤون الاجتماعيه في كل حاجه ده
بيخليها مطمنه ومرتاحه
كلمه السر في نجاح العلاقه الزوجيه
مع بعض علشان الدنيا تمشي محبه وود بما
يرضي الله اكثر من كده هتلاقي حياتك ماشيه
زي الفل انا متجوز بقى لي سنتين ونصف
وعندي مصطفى عمري انا وامراتي ما تخالفنا
مع بعض في حاجه
[موسيقى]
من عمان ينضم الينا زوجان لاكثر من 35
عاما نهى الجبير والسيد جاد الرب اهلا
بكما نهى واا سيد جاد يسعد صباحكم معنا
تسمعني
يسعد صباحك يسعد صباحكم يعني باعتقادكم
انتم الاثنين
يعني شو كلمه السر السعاده الزوجيه للناس
اللي بتشوفنا اليوم كلمه السر
اوكي انا بالنسبه لي كلمه السر الصبر
والتفاهم
والمحبه والحياه السعيده انت اللي بتصنعي
المحبه والحياه السعيده
والصبر طبعا قبل اي شيء لازم يعني الواحد
كمان انه يسمع الكلام يفهم الحياه اللي
قدام منه كيف عشان تقدر تستمر في حياتك
كلمات حلوه نجحت ها العلاقه وخلتها تدوم
لاكثر من 35 سنه
اكيد طبعا كلمه شكرا كلمه يسلموا ايديك
المواد
والثقه في التعامل والامان يعني
حبك بالكلمات
يمكن افعل اكثر من كلمات
بين الازواج بتصير فيه صعود ونزول في
العلاقه يعني الحياه ما بتكون كامله ميه
بالميه من حيث السعاده الزوجيه لكن كيف
بنقدر نحن باقل الخسائر وبالمينيوم بنجحه
هذه العلاقه بنخليها تدوم سنين وعقود
اوكي
انك انت تكوني متفاهمه في الحياه وبتفهمها
تكون في الصبر ويكون الواحد خلوك ويقدر
يتفاهم في الحياه ويقدر انه يسعد اللي
قدام منه عشان هو كمان يكون سعيد ويكون
صبور
والحقيقه الزوجيه اما بيكون فيها اولاد
كمان
اكثر
وبتقدري انت تمارسي حياتك تكون عاديه يعني
كمان تكون مطيعه الزوجه المطيعه اللي بتحب
زوجها بتحب بيتها واولادها اكيد ان هي
بتحب كل شيء في الحياه
وتقدري تصبري في الحياه السعيده
فانت بتكوني الصبوره في الحياه وبكون
مبسوطه وسعيده وهذا اهمها
الزوج
طب نهى وسجاد ارجو ان تتفضلوا بالبقاء
معانا اذهب الان الذي معانا صانعه المحتوى
ماما سعاد وزوجها ابراهيم ابراهيم زوجاني
اكثر من 43 عاما اهلا بك من سعاد واهلا
ابراهيم هل تعتقدون بالفعل انه التمتع
بثقافه التقدير والامتنان يجعل الحياه
الزوجيه السعيده
[موسيقى]
لما الانسان يكبر عقله
ويتفهم الحياه بشكل الصحيح ممكن تشترك
الامور مو بس في الحياه الزوج كل حياتي
يعني لازم يفهم يفهم انه كيف هي سياسه
الحياه يعني يعتبر
الفيزياء مثل الفيزياء
الفيزيائيه الكيميائيه
يفهم طبيعه المراه انه المراه متطلبات
المطر
[موسيقى]
بين جلستهم هل هذه المسافه هي سر السعاده
اللي انتم بتتركوا المسافه بينكم يعني
مسافه لكل انسان يعبر عن نفسه يرتاح ياخذ
بريك من الاخر ولولح لحظات لايام
طبعا
يعني المسافه هذه ضروريه ترى
شو اسمك تقول شخص يعني مده طويله همم يعني
واحد امام الله لا بتصير يعني تنافرات بس
كل مره اساس نجاح حبيتها انه تكون لها
حياتها الزوجيه وحياتها الخاصه في الشغل
على يعني حاجتين تشتغل على نجاحها همم
المعنوي والمادي
وتكون لها صديقاتها الخاصه همم اقربائها
معارفها ومن ضمن حياتها هذه همم حياتها
الزوجيه بس من تبقى بس قاعده وتعد حركات
الزوج الزوج وين راح وين جاء اتاخر ويامن
تكلم هذه الروح حياتي
شو
التناسب
بالافكار
بالرافات يعني ما يصير قد علو هذه يعني
احتمال همم نسافر العالم وما اخذ شهاده
عاليه واختار وحده انسانه بسيطه لولا
مستحيل يتفاهموا اهم شيء التفاهم والتناسب
طيب سيد ابراهيم
للمراه او للرجل
ومن ضمن هاي حياتهم
يخصصون هو وقت للحياه الزوجيه حتى لو تصير
بحياتكم ممله ونكد ابراهيم بحسب الدراسه
كذلك انه يعني كل واحد فينا عنده سلبيات
والدراسه تقول لازم همم على الزوجين تركيز
على الايجابيات بدل السلبيات هل تؤيد هذه
الدراسه قال له التركيز الكبير يكون على
الايجابيات
بالتاكيد اني هذا كلش هذا النظريه وبعدين
هو الانسان
نفسه انه انا اريد استمر انا في في بدايه
حياتي يعني مقرر انه يستمر فهذا القرار من
التقدم اني بعد ما درست حالتي بعد ما درست
حالك زوجتي وبعدين ساره وعندنا اطفال وهي
حتى وهي العلاقات العامه انا من قبر استمر
فيتحمل نتائج القرار اللي يعني يشتغل
اغنيه اصاله مؤخرا شكرا على الكلمه الحلوه
اللي بتتقلمت تتغير
السيره ماما سعاد انت في كلمات كنت بتحبي
تسمعيها من استاذ ابراهيم يعني كان نفسك
يقول لك اياها دائما او بالتكرار اكثر من
مره
اكيد يعني كلمات مثلا شكر من يجونا ضيوف
واقيم يعني بيهم
باحتفاء وايش اسمه والبيتنا نظيف وطبخ
وملقات حلو يعني يعجبني من يطلعون يعني
يقول لي شكرا رفعت راسي انت يعني
هالزمان مالتك قليله يعني تشوفين المراه
تجيها قطاعه
مستعده هاي الحيطان يشيلها الكلمه يا
حبايبي من الرجل او الكلمه من المراه
مو طبيعيه خاصه الكلمه الطيبه
الجميع ان احنا بداخلنا طفل
من تطري على اليد قولي له عافيه عافيه انت
ساعدني
بيكون صديق امه وابوه ترا الكبارهم نفس
الشيء سواء الرجل او المراه طبعا
الاصاله احنا طبعا المتابعه جدا هاي وحده
اثنين اكو شغله الحروب بالعالم
صارت بسبب كلمه كلمه هي تسبب حرب بندول
فالكلمه الانسان يدرك ما يقول ما يتصرف
كده هي اللي تخلي الحياه مستقيمه
وتمشي
بليونه وسلاسه
معبره جدا
بابا تليفون
يعني بدي اقول لكم الكلمه والكلمه جارحه
ما سامعين المثل يقول الجرح يطيب يعني
يشفى الكلمه ما تشفى فاحبابي الازواج لسه
جدا احباب يعني حافظوا على الكلمه حافظوا
على هاي الكلمه انه ما تنطقوها الا تفكرون
شنو وراها لان هذه الكلمه تسبب يعني هدم
البيوت او بالعكس تتثبت اعمار البيوت ويا
ربي يسعد الجميع
الكثير من المحبه الله يديم الوفي عند
الجميع شكرا جزيلا لكما ماما سعاد وزوجها
ابراهيم وزوجها اكثر من 43 عاما من
ديترويت وادى من عمان زوجها لاكثر من 35
عاما وس
شكرا لكم